while hidden figures featured actors
betrayin Catherine Mary and Dorothy
documentary filmmakers use a camera to
show real people sharing their real
stories in doing so they illuminate the
human condition in a way that is
brilliantly insightful often astonishing
but above all troops here are the
nominees for Best Documentary Feature
fire at sea
Gianfranco Rosi and Donatella saloon I
am NOT your Negro raw Peck brain bonuses
and able past life animated Roger Roth
William and Zhu Rizzoli
Oh Jay made in America Ezra Edelman and
Caroline water 13th Ava Duvernay Victor
Abbott and Halle Berry and the Oscar
goes to
Oh Jay made in America Caroline one of
those
[Music]
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Ezra Edelman and Caroline water layer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thirty huh okay um first of all this is
incredible I I want to thank Caroline
Waterlow for going in this journey with
me
I yes give it up I want to thank the
Academy for acknowledging this
untraditional film I want to thank you
SPN for allowing us the canvas and the
time to tell this story this is the only
way it could be told but I want to
acknowledge that I wouldn't be standing
here tonight if not for two people who
aren't here with us Ron Goldman Nicole
Brown this is for them and their
families it is also for others the
victims of police violence police
brutality racially motivated violence
and criminal injustice this is their
story as well as Ron Nicole's I am
honored to accept this award on all
their behalf thank you
[Applause]